changing the ph of a solution can affect
the solubility of a slightly soluble
salt
for example if we took some solid lead
to fluoride which is a white solid and
we put it in some distilled water the
solid is going to reach an equilibrium
with the ions in solution
lead to fluoride forms lead to plus ions
and fluoride anions and a one to two
mole ratio so if we have two lead two
plus ions in this diagram we need four
fluoride anions at equilibrium the rate
of dissolution is equal to the rate of
precipitation and therefore the amount
of solid and the concentration of ions
in solution remains constant and this
forms a saturated solution of lead ii
fluoride
to the system at equilibrium we're going
to add some h plus ions so by increasing
the concentration of h plus ions in
solution we're decreasing the ph of the
solution
when the h plus ions are added to the
solution most of them react with the
fluoride anions that are present so h
plus plus f minus forms hf comparing the
first diagram to the second diagram i
just happen to add three h plus ions
which will react with three of the
fluoride anions that are present to
produce three hf
notice how the concentration of fluoride
anions in solution has decreased from
the first diagram to the second diagram
because of the addition of the h plus
ions
so the system was at equilibrium and the
concentration of fluoride anions was
decreased according to le chatelier's
principle the system will shift in the
direction that decreases the stress so
if the stress is decreased concentration
of fluoride anions the system will shift
to the right to make more fluoride
anions
and when the system shifts to the right
more lead to fluoride dissolves to
increase the concentration of pb2 plus
and fluoride anion we can see that
comparing the second diagram to the
third diagram so the amount of solid has
gotten smaller since some of that led to
fluoride dissolved and we've increased
the concentration of pb2 plus and f
minus in solution
the solid keeps dissolving and the
concentration of ions keeps increasing
in solution until the system reaches
equilibrium
so for a saturated solution of lead to
fluoride at equilibrium
decreasing the ph or making the solution
more acidic by increasing the
concentration of h plus ions increases
the solubility of lead ii fluoride which
is why we saw more of the solid dissolve
when the h plus ions were added
this effect of decreasing the ph and
increasing the solubility of a slightly
soluble salt happens whenever the
slightly soluble salt contains a basic
anion
for this example the basic anion is the
fluoride anion which reacts with the
added h plus ions and when the basic
anion reacts that decreases the
concentration of that basic anion which
caused the equilibrium to shift to the
right
and there are many other examples of
basic anions two more would be the
hydroxide anion and the carbonate anion
and if a compound contains a basic anion
such as the hydroxide anion hydroxide
functions as a base and reacts with h
plus ions to form h2o
so therefore the solubility of a
compound containing a hydroxide ion
would increase as h plus ions are added
to the solution
it's also important to note for this
lead ii fluoride problem if the ph is
decreased at a constant temperature
the ksp value for pbf2 remains constant
so the molar solubility does increase
but the ksp value remains the same
this time instead of lead to fluoride
let's look at lead ii chloride lead ii
chloride is also a white solid so if we
dissolved some in solution eventually we
would reach an equilibrium between the
solid and the ions in solution so this
diagram here shows a saturated solution
of lead to chloride and the system is at
equilibrium
and to the system at equilibrium we
decrease the ph by adding h plus ions to
the solution
in this case the chloride anions aren't
basic enough to react with the h plus
ions therefore we do not form hcl and
the concentration of chloride anions
remains the same as it was in the
original diagram
so if the concentration of chloride ions
remains the same and the concentration
of lead two plus ions would remain the
same the system is still at equilibrium
and decreasing the ph had no effect on
the solubility of the solids so we have
the same amount of lead ii chloride
solid on the bottom of the beaker in
both diagrams
so whenever an anion is an extremely
weak base like the chloride anion we say
that this is an anion of negligible
basicity and the solubility of salts
with anions of negligible basicity is
unaffected by changes in ph